estos seis hombres que forman parte del
círculo de confianza de Vladimir Putin
son quizás los únicos capaces de influir
en el presidente ruso una de las
personas que habla al oído de Putin es
el ministro de defensa de Rusia sergey
su confidente desde hace muchos años
este hombre de 66 años carece de
experiencia militar pero se le atribuye
la toma de crimea en 2014 y se le ha
relacionado con varios envenenamientos
de agentes alguien con una verdadera
experiencia militar es Valery gerasimov
el jefe de Estado Mayor de las fuerzas
armadas de Rusia quien también es lea la
Putin un sistema en el que Putin es el
jefe de la mafia y todo el mundo le teme
todo el mundo es sus súbdito nadie
quiere tomar una posición independiente
alguien que lo sabe muy bien es el
director de inteligencia exterior de
Rusia sergeiner skin es reacio a
oponerse a Putin en un intenso
intercambio Putin lo presionó para saber
si apoyaba la decisión de reconocer como
estados independientes a dos regiones
separatistas de Ucrania apoyadas por el
kremlin
apoya su apoyas habla directamente
apoyo la propuesta dígalo entonces
Gracias puedes sentarse pero es nicolay
patricef el secretario del Consejo de
Seguridad considerado el hombre con más
influencia sobre el presidente ruso ha
sido descrito como el Halcón de Halcones
patriciaf está a favor de la guerra y es
el menos indicado para frenar a Putin
arcadi rottenberg podría ser la voz de
la razón el multimillonario es amigo de
la infancia de Putin ha sido golpeado
por las sanciones de occidente pero los
lazos Entre él y el presidente ruso se
han debilitado
ha intentado utilizar la distancia como
proyección de poder pero también crea
algunas medidas de salud o incluso de
seguridad Tú tienes alguien que sabe
cómo se produce en este tipo de intentos
de asesinato ha estado involucrado en
algunos de ellos
es por eso que Putin tiene a su lado a
Víctor soloto quien dirige la guardia
Nacional de Rusia una fuerza de 3000
hombres cuyo objetivo es proteger a
Vladimir Putin a toda costa